a new survey has revealed that four in
10 people who class themselves as
straight
say they might be attracted to someone
of the same sex
if the right person came along now when
the 86 percent of us who identify as
heterosexual were asked if we would
25 said that it was unlikely but they
wouldn't rule it out
10 percent answered maybe if i really
liked them
and another 4 were unequivocal and said
yes
that would include nick this represents
a significant change even since 2015
when a similar poll was conducted only
50 years after the stonewall riots
which led to the first pride rallies
being organized in america
this is a monumental cultural shift
celebrate it
we should but as protests outside
birmingham schools highlight
there is a great deal left worth
fighting for especially
in addressing homophobia among minority
communities
and neither this country nor america
have yet elected an openly gay leader
still
four in ten is hugely significant just
think about that for a second
that means two of the five people
who sit around this table every week
would be open
to a gay experience would you
[Music]
so would you well i mean i i
i i'm gonna get to that oh i've got
i've got a little thing i've got a
little thing to do which i'll talk about
and i'd
but i'll i'll class myself on the scale
there's a scale i think
it's a spectrum there is and i see the
way that you look at nick sometime
and i am very concerned that you're not
going to answer my question so i'm going
to put you back on the spot
would you okay well well to be honest um
have you i mean i've i have had gay men
hit on me a lot
right and uh that's not my question
that's a sexual experience and so i've
had a sexual experience because
they have touched me in ways where
they've tried to come on to me and i've
had to
say i'm straight so yeah i think that's
that
yeah i think you've just defeated your
own argument because i think you
you yourself are unwilling to accept
that maybe they're harder
fair enough okay let's be serious never
say never never say no never saying okay
look at how happy it looks right so
addressing your central point i went to
an event this weekend actually
um in a bandstand and there was a
conduct and the conductor was gay
and he gave a little talk and because
obviously it's pride month and he gave a
little talk
that we all listened to and at the end
of it he said something that really
struck a chord with me because
he stood there and he said i just want
to say thank you for letting me
be me and it really struck a chord with
me because i thought hang on a second
who am i to tell you who you can
and cannot be sexually attracted to and
be sexually intimate with
and it really made me the fact that he
had to say
thank you to the audience you went out
with a lesbian didn't you
i didn't go out with a lesbian i went on
a date once with a lesbian you went out
with a lesbian
yeah early because for me yeah doing it
yes but look at what i'm going to
defensively answer the question
honestly and concisely with her
dithering around you could learn from me
magic so you went out with a lesbian
yeah i proactively joined a lesbian
dating site once
because i was so fed up with men and i
thought this i've had enough
all of them
it was it was uh it was interesting
because she happened i didn't know this
at times she happens to be deaf in both
ears
and she was very loud and she was asking
me and this will mean nothing to people
outside of london but
it was a daytime day and she was asking
me very loudly um
how you know had i always known that i
was a lesbian and all these people kept
tearing around
and there was a couple of people that
recognized me off the apprentice i found
the whole thing
quite embarrassing we only had one day
and i told a white lie to get myself out
of that situation so i apologize oh you
didn't go fast
for space then no it was an afternoon
date what kind of lady do you think i am
anyway
i mean there's a lot of like there's two
of us on this panel then i mean
me personally i'm very comfortable my
sexuality but damon salvatore uh
straight
okay but damon salvatore from the
vampire diaries is problematic
uh henry cavill uh from uh henry cavill
from uh who's in mission impossible
recently he did that thing with his arms
did that arouse you ah i wouldn't say
that's really i don't know if you
realize how how important it is on
television for a young black man to just
say
that they found another man attractive
like seriously hats off to you and
likewise for for a muslim man which is
actually why i'm happy you asked me that
question
um and it's why i eventually did answer
it because actually uh
you didn't answer it i said never say
never yes they never say never and so
in other words i would be you know
concerned i'm in a relationship with
sexuality
exactly and 52 of british muslim surveys
said they would ban homosexuality in
this country
and zero percent said they'd find them
more acceptable so you what you've just
said there is actually
it's really important i'd say the other
the other issue i talk about is
um in relation to christianity yeah
because i i was a christian up until the
age of 21
uh and i i found a way to rationalize it
because and this is the message i give
to
gay people if they want to talk to
people who are a christian
homosexuality isn't a choice we can
establish that on the basis that
nobody would choose to face something
face so much stigma they had to invent a
word for it
on that basis if you call homosexuality
a sin you're saying that sin
can be something that's both involuntary
and permanent
now if sin something that's involuntary
and permanent that means it can't be
removed and it's unjust and if sin can't
be removed
jesus died for nothing so the logic of
christianity
says that homosexuality cannot be a sin
can i just say in my case i can say
never means never i have no
issue if that's absolutely fantastic i i
cannot imagine
any set of circumstances in which let
alone a man would be attracted to me
that i would be attracted to a man i
just cannot imagine
but rachel there's something i've always
wanted to ask you you
went to a lot of girls schools were you
ever drawn to any school girls or
school mistresses you know you meant to
have this sort of crush that's a very
good question nick
trying to think i think the answer is
yes
yeah i'm happy to admit on that note can
we move to the scale because it is a
spectrum and so when you've said
never ever nick just can't i'm not i'm
not knocking it's not no but it's not a
binary let's look at this let's look at
that
what am i going to be looking for so if
you look at that right it's from a scale
of zero
to six where zero is exclusively
heterosexual
and six is exclusively homosexual so
it's not a binary so you could be
somewhere around one
for example okay if it makes you happy
yeah so let's ask these questions so
michelle where do you think you sit on
the zero to six scale
um like as a general rule
all probably more towards the earlier
numbers but
like i'm very one two we've gotta this
is quick fire all right
maybe three three there we are this is
your reward for answering the question
have a pride flag nick where do you say
it what is it zero is it absolutely
heterosexual i think i'm zero
really yes
yeah no wow course femi between one and
one and two
all right okay nice and honestly i'm i'm
kind of probably around the one scale
what can i just say as well one of the
things that frustrates me you saw those
two lesbians getting
tactics in the news because they were on
a bus and they had this group of guys
that was awesome
and i actually think that sexuality
isn't for other people's titillation and
i think there's this real
misconception look at those two lesbians
lads really
and i just i don't like it and i think
porn's got a lot to answer for for that
that's something i'm frustrated about
today as well
the frustrations are out the whole
course i forgot to say that
when i've ever asked if i've had a
same-sex relationship i'll say no but
it's something my husband complains of a
lot with me
is perhaps the key issue here because
even though they've announced this week
that they're trying to rework the
lessons
you still have a set of parents who
still are protesting
and you have this key issue who decides
whether children learn about
sexuality about tolerance whatever it
might be is it the role of the parents
or is it the role of the state and that
one is all run and run
but i mean what you said about the two
lesbians who were beaten up
uh by a couple of kids on a bus because
they wouldn't kiss
i think that just shows how essential it
is that we have those lessons in school
and that's what prince william was
talking about when he said that he
wouldn't
he'd be very happy if one of his
children was gay but
um he would be very worried about
you know the challenges they faced being
gay anyway
we must now move to straight talker
of the week and the hunt for the next
conservative party leader is finally
starting to draw to a close and right
about time
family days out haven't been the same
since theresa may announced her
resignation we've had endless coverage
of candidates
battling it out to show tory members
their big c
conservative to the core we're now down
to the final two but there's still
three weeks before we find out
who'll be crowned this year's
[Music]
x factor winner i mean our next
prime minister in all the madness
there's one voice that truly
speaks to the nation maxwell
the dog right something we haven't
discussed so far
is the tory leadership contest
so we've got jeremy hunt against boris
johnson the final two
we should know the result at the end of
july
so what are your thoughts on that
broadcaster nikki campbell's pooch has
made his mark on twitter after making it
very clear what he thinks about it
all maxwell i totally agree there's
nothing left to say
they're all barking mad for that awesome
response you
are our political pooch of the week
so that was maxwell thrilled to have
been on the pledge yes next week
maxwell debates the backstop
that's it from us for this week but if
you want to join in the debate just
search for
the pledge on facebook or twitter and
you can now also listen to the pledge
with apple podcasts
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
straight talking